STAY WITH UNG
COVERAGE, FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
HANNITY STARTS RIGHT N NOW.
>> Hannity: WELCOME TO
HANNITY.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
WHAT A NIGHT THIS HAS BEEN.
WE HAVE A FULLY LOADED SHOW.
I BEGIN TONIGHT, I HAVE SEEN A
LOT OF STATE OF THE UNIONS OVER
THE YEARS.
TONIGHT, PERHAPS, BY FAR THE
BEST I’VE EVER SEEN.
I AM NOW IT’S MY 31ST YEAR ON
THE YEAR ON MY RADIO.
TONIGHT, EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD
BE PROUD OF THEIR COUNTRY.
WE ARE NOW LOOKING AND OBSERVING
A TALE OF VARIED TWO DIFFERENT
FAIRY AMERICANS.
YOU ALWAYS HEAR ABOUT CHOICE
ELECTIONS.
WE ARE ABOUT TO HAVE ONE AND 273
DAYS ON ONE SIDE VIEW OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AT THE DO-NOTHING DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE OFFERED NOTHING BUT
THREE YEARS HATE, RAGE,
SOCIALISM, CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
LIES.
SLANDER, BUT SEARCH MEANT,
CHARACTER ASSASSIN.
ABORTION AFTER BIRTH, AS THE
VIRGINIA GOVERNOR TOLD US.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, USE OF THE
PRESIDENT TONIGHT.
HE IS DELIVERED THE COMPELLING,
UPLIFTING SPEECH OF HIS LIFE.
HIGHLIGHTING THE GROUNDBREAKING
SUCCESS.
JOBS IN AMERICA BOOMING.
INCOME SOARING.
POVERTY IN AMERICA LOWERING.
WE ARE HIGHLY RESPECTED ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
TONIGHT WAS ABOUT AMERICAN
GREATNESS.
IT INCLUDES BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO MAKE THIS COUNTRY THE SINGLE
GREATEST PLACE GOD EVER GAVE
MAN.
AND MOMENTS AGO, THE PRESIDENT
HONORED THE PARENTS OF MURDERED
BY ISIS.
A LITTLE GIRL RECEIVED A NEW
SCHOLARSHIP TONIGHT TO ADVANCE
HER LIFE AND HER EDUCATION.
WE MET A GENERAL WHO WAS ONE OF
THE LAST SURVIVING AIRMAN.
WE MET A BRAVE MEMBER OF THE
BORDER CONTROL.
A SPECIAL MOMENT WITH THE FAMILY
OF AN AMERICAN SOLDIER SERVING
ABROAD.
IT BROUGHT THE HOUSE DOWN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> BUT AMY, THERE IS ONE MORE
THING TONIGHT WE HAVE A VERY
SPECIAL SURPRISE.
I AM THRILLED TO INFORM YOU THAT
YOUR HUSBAND IS BACK FROM
DEPLOYMENT.
HE IS HERE WITH US TONIGHT.
WE COULDN’T KEEP HIM WAITING ANY
LONGER.
>> WELL, THAT’S A SHOCK AND ALL.
DESPITE ALL OF THESE POWERFUL
MOMENTS WHAT DID BC DENY?
DEMOCRATS BARELY CRACKING A
SMILE.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT NANCY PELOSI
WAS DOING.
IT ALMOST LOOKED LIKE A
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" SKIT FOR
THE ENTIRE SPEECH.
THEY ARE CLEARLY LIVING TONIGHT
IN A VERY DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVE
REALITY.
ANOTHER AMERICA THAT I DON’T
RECOGNIZE.
ONE FULL OF NONSTOP CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
PELOSI TRYING SO HARD.
IT LOOK HOW MISERABLE SHE WAS.
AT THE END OF HIS PRESIDENCY
SPEECH SHE RIPPED UP THE COPY OF
THE SPEECH.
AND JUST DEFENDED DOING SO.
ONE OF THE MOST CLASSLESS THINGS
EVER DONE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
STATE OF THE UNION.
AND ALL THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT,
SHE COULD BARELY BRING HERSELF
TO STAND UP FOR THE ROARING
ECONOMY OR ANY OF AMERICA’S
GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE VETERAN’S UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE DROPPED TO A RECORD LOW.
A RECORD NUMBER OF YOUNG
AMERICANS ARE NOW EMPLOYED.
REAL MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS
NOW AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL EVER
RECORDED.
WE WILL ALWAYS PROTECT PATIENCE
WITH PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS.
DRUG OVERDOSE DEATHS DECLINED
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN NEARLY 30
YEARS.
>> Hannity: WELL, PRETTY
POWERFUL.
ALL THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT WE WILL
BE LISTENING AND SHOWING THE
PRESIDENT’S ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT
HE TALKED ABOUT TONIGHT.
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
PELOSI DIDN’T EVEN STAND FOR THE
LITTLE GIRL WHO RECEIVED A
SCHOLARSHIP.
IS THAT NOT SOMETHING EVERY
AMERICAN CAN AGREE ON?
APPARENTLY NOT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AN OPPORTUNITY SCHOLARSHIP
HAS BECOME AVAILABLE.
IT IS GOING TO YOU AND YOU WILL
SOON BE HEADING TO THE SCHOOL OF
YOUR CHOICE.
>> Hannity: REMEMBER WHEN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT BALTIMORE?
13 HIGH SCHOOLS, ALL OF THESE
LIBERAL CITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
RUN FOR DECADES BY LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS.
13 HIGH SCHOOLS IN BALTIMORE
ALONE WERE NOT A SINGLE KID
PROFICIENT IN READING OR MATH.
NOT ONE.
WE CAN’T FEEL LIKE IT’S LIKE
THAT.
GOD BLESS THAT GIRL AND COULD
LOOK TO HER AND HER FUTURE.
AND NANCY PELOSI BARELY EVEN
APPLAUDING ANY OF HER PRESIDENTS
SPECIAL GUESTS.
AT THAT MUCH CONTEMPT IN YOUR
HEART, AND OF COURSE PELOSI’S
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES WERE JUST
AS BAD.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE, 72% OF
THE NEW JOBS CREATED FOR WOMEN
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WATCH THIS.
A TALE OF TWO AMERICAS.
>> LAST YEAR WOMEN FILLED 72% OF
ALL NEW JOBS ADDED.
>> Hannity: I SEE A LOT OF
WOMEN AND WHITE.
DESPITE THE UNYIELDING RAGE FROM
THE DEMOCRATS, HE DELIVERED A
POWERFUL OPTIMISTIC, PATRIOTIC
SPEECH.
WITH REAL STATISTICS.
AND SUCCESS BEHIND IT.
CONSERVATISM WORKS.
IT’S WORKING NOW, AND IT’S
WORKING FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JOBS ARE BOOMING.
INCOMES ARE SOARING.
POVERTY IS PLUMMETING.
CRIME IS FALLING.
CONFIDENCE TO SURGING.
AND OUR COUNTRY IS THRIVING AND
HIGHLY RESPECTED AGAIN.
THIS IS A BLUE COLLAR BOOM.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, WE MUST
NEVER FORGET THAT THE ONLY
VICTORIES THAT MATTER IN
WASHINGTON ARE VICTORIES THAT
DELIVER FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE ARE THE HEART OF OUR
COUNTRY.
THEIR DREAMS ARE THE SOLE OF OUR
AND OUR LOVE IS WHAT POWERS AND
SUSTAINS OUR COUNTRY.
WE MUST ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT OUR
JOB IS TO PUT AMERICA FIRST.
>> Hannity: PUBLIC SERVANTS
SERVING THE PEOPLE.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
SINCE THE PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN
OFFICE OUR ECONOMY HAS GENERATED
OVER 7 MILLION NEW JOBS.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT IS LOWEST IN
HALF A CENTURY.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATES FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, HAVE REACHED
THE LOWEST LEVELS IN HISTORY.
WE HAVE A RECORD NUMBER OF YOUNG
AMERICANS WHO ARE NOW EMPLOYED.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN POVERTY HAS NOW
DECLINED TO THE LOWEST RATE EVER
RECORDED.
A 70 YEAR RECORD LOW AND
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR WOMEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
72% OF ALL NEW JOBS ADDED ARE
GOING TO WOMEN IN THE WORKFORCE.
VETERAN UNEMPLOYMENT, THAT RATE
DROPPING A GUN TO A RECORD LOW.
DISABLED AMERICANS, AN ALL-TIME
LOW.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR
WORKERS WITHOUT A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA IS NOW AT A RECORD LOW.
7 MILLION FELLOW AMERICANS ARE
OFF OF FOOD STAMPS.
10 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
LIFTED OFF OF WELFARE.
THE NET WORTH OF THE BOTTOM HALF
OF RAGE EARNERS HAS INCREASED BY
A WHOPPING 74%.
LOW INCOME WORKERS HAVE SEEN A
16% PAY INCREASE.
MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS NOW
AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL EVER
RECORDED.
12,000 NEW FACTORIES, WHO SAID
THOSE JOBS ARE NOT COMING BACK?
A BOOMING STOCK MARKET.
THAT MEANS AMERICA IS WINNING.
AMERICA HAS FORGOTTEN MEN AND
WOMEN ARE WINNING.
TONIGHT SPEECH WAS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE MASSIVE SUCCESS OF THE
TRUMP AGENDA.
AT THE PRESIDENT ALSO TOOK TIME
ALONG WITH THE FIRST LADY,
MELANIA TRUMP, AND THEY GAVE A
VERY SPECIAL AWARD TO ONE OF THE
SINGLE MOST INFLUENTIAL
IMPORTANT STOIC VOICES THIS
COUNTRY HAS EVER KNOWN.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> HERE TONIGHT IS A SPECIAL MAN
MAN.
BELOVED BY MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
WHO JUST RECEIVED A STAGE FOR
ADVANCED CANCER DIAGNOSIS.
THIS IS NOT GOOD NEWS.
BUT WHAT IS GOOD NEWS IS THAT HE
HAS THE GREATEST FIGHTER AND
WINNER THAT YOU WILL EVER MEET.
RUSH LIMBAUGH.
THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR DECADES OF
TIRELESS DEVOTION TO OUR COUNTRY
COUNTRY.
>> Hannity: I THOUGHT THE LEFT
CELEBRATED THE FREE OPEN
EXCHANGE OF IDEAS AND OPINIONS.
BUT APPARENTLY NOT CONSERVATIVE
ONES.
WE PRAY FOR RUSH LIMBAUGH
TONIGHT.
HE HAS A FIGHTER.
THE BABE RUTH OF TALK RADIO.
HE PAVED THE WAY FOR ALL OF US
THAT DO OPINION AND TALK RADIO
IN THE COUNTRY.
HE CLEARED THE PATH, WE ALL GOT
TO WALK THROUGH AN EASIER PATH
BECAUSE OF HIM.
PERHAPS NO ONE IN MODERN HISTORY
HAS ADVANCED THE CAUSE OF
PATRIOTISM, FREE SPEECH, LOVE OF
COUNTRY, LOVE OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES, MORE THAN A RUSH.
WITHOUT RUSH, NOTHING I DO HERE
WOULD BE POSSIBLE.
THAT PATH THAT HE FORGED BEFORE
ALL OF US IN THE CONSERVATIVE
MOVEMENT ALL OVER AMERICA AND
FOUGHT EACH AND EVERY SINGLE DAY
TO MAKE THIS A MORE PERFECT
UNION.
EVERYONE WHO HAS EVER BATTLED
CANCER, KNOWS SOMEONE WHO HAS
BATTLED CANCER, YOU DO
UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT.
HOW WILL EARTH SHATTERING THIS
DIAGNOSIS CAN BE.
SOME OF THE SAME POLITICIANS,
WELL THEY GO ON CONTROVERSIAL
SHOWS OR HOWARD STERN.
HE SAID CONTROVERSIAL THINGS.
WE OUT TO CELEBRATE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH WHETHER YOU AGREE OR
DISAGREE.
WE ARE BLESSED TO LIVE IN A
COUNTRY THAT, THANK GOD, WE HAVE
THE GREATEST BEST SCIENTISTS,
DOCTORS, HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD.
RUSH IS BLESSED WITH A FAMILY.
WE’LL PRAY FOR A SPEEDY
RECOVERY.
ALSO A FULL ANALYSIS TO THE
SENATOR’S ADDRESS.
SO MUCH MORE, WE ALSO HAVE A LOT
OF OTHER BIG BREAKING NEWS TO
COVER TODAY.
WE WILL START WITH IS KNOWN AS
THE DUMPSTER FIRE OF THE IOWA
CAUCUS.
THIS LOBBYIST TRAIN WRECK IN
HISTORY.
IT’S PROBABLY AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
IT HAS BEEN MORE THAN 24 HOURS
SINCE THE VOTES TOOK PLACE.
WE STILL DO NOT HAVE THE FULL
RESULTS.
AND FOR THE BETTER PART OF THE
DAY, WE DIDN’T HAVE ANY RESULTS
AT ALL.
NOTHING.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BLAMING IT ON A
CODING ERROR AND ITS ELECTION
SOFTWARE.
AND PROBLEMS WITH ITS BACKUP
SYSTEM.
WHILE, REMINDS ME OF THEIR
PROMISES OF OBAMACARE.
MILLIONS LOST THEIR DOCTORS,
MILLIONS LOST THEIR PLAN.
WE ALMOST PAY 200% MORE.
WE DIDN’T SAVE ANYTHING.
40% OF AMERICANS ONLY HAVE ONE
OPTION ON OBAMACARE.
THAT’S THE PROMISE OF THE LEFT.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DESTROYED ONE BIG CITY IN THIS
COUNTRY AFTER ANOTHER.
THEY WANT TO CONTROL YOUR
HEALTH CARE, THEY WANT TO
CONTROL YOUR BUSINESSES, NOW
THEY WANT TO TAKE THE LIGHT BULB
OF THE THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
AND THEY CAN EVEN COUNT THE
VOTES IN THE STATE OF IOWA.
TONIGHT IT IS CLEAR, ACTUALLY
NOT CLEAR, WHY A HUGE PERCENTAGE
OF THE VOTE IS M.I.A.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED.
ONE THING WE CAN TELL YOU, I’M
NOT CERTAIN, BERNIE SANDERS
LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE AFTER BERNIE
AGAIN.
AN ISLAND HERE.
YEAH, THEY STUCK TO THE DECK
AGAINST YOU.
THEY RIGGED IT.
THEY ARE RAKING IT AGAIN, LIKELY
IOWA FRONT-RUNNER COULD HAVE
BEEN.
NO ONE WILL KNOW.
QUID PRO QUO JOE.
LOOKS LIKE A DISASTER FOR HIM.
THIS COMES ON HEELS OF
DEMOCRATIC OFFICIALS.
THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE RULES
AGAIN BECAUSE THEY HAVE A SHOT
AT BERNIE WENDING.
WINNING.
CHANGING THE RULES TO MAKE
SUPERDELEGATES HAVE MORE POWER.
BIDEN IS FALLING APART, SO MAYBE
YOU CAN HELP MICHAEL BLOOMBERG
IN CASE WE NEED HIM AT SOME
POINT.
MAYBE HE CAN BUY HIMSELF INTO
THE DEBATE STAGE.
EVEN MICHAEL MOORE IS FURIOUS
ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS 2016 ON STEROIDS ALL
OVER AGAIN.
HISTORY MORE THAN REPEATING
ITSELF.
THEY CHEATED BERNIE, AND THEN
THEY USED DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER
AND LEAKED IT TO THE PRESS.
WYATT?
SO THEY COULD SPY ON A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
AND THEN DEEP INTO HIS
PRESIDENCY.
ALL OF THAT HAPPENED.
AND THE DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER?
HILLARY CLINTON PAID FOR.
APPARENTLY DEMOCRATS DIDN’T TALK
ABOUT RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
UNLESS IT’S DONALD TRUMP.
AS CHRONICLED BY THE
JANUARY 11TH, 2017 POLITICAL
INVESTIGATION AND BY UKRAINIAN
COURTS.
NDNNOBODY SEEM TO CARE.
LIKE THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT QUID
PRO QUOTE JOE.
THIS CONTINUES, WE ARE ON THE
VERGE OF A CIVIL WAR WITHIN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IF THEY WILL SOON NOMINATE A
RADICAL, DEVOUT, COMMUNIST.
IN THE CASE OF BERNIE SANDERS
WHO HONEYMOONED IN THE SOVIET
UNION.
WE WILLLOOK AT THE ENTHUSIASM GA
DESPITE EVENTUALLY RUNNING
UNCONTESTED.
THE PRESIDENT DIDN’T NEED A LOT
OF PEOPLE TO SHOW UP IN IOWA
LAST NIGHT.
A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF IOWA
REPUBLICANS TURNED OUT TO CAUCUS
VERGE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT WAS THE MOST EVER FOR A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
MEANWHILE, DEMOCRATIC NUMBERS
ARE WAY DOWN FROM THE OBAMA
YEARS.
DEMOCRATS WERE COUNTING ON
BARACK OBAMA LEVELS OF
ENTHUSIASM.
AND THEY GOT HILLARY CLINTON
NUMBERS INSTEAD.
A FRIENDLY REMINDER, HILLARY
LOST THE STATE OF IOWA AND LOST
THE ELECTION.
IT’S IMPORTANT TO ASK YOURSELF,
AS IT IS FOR EVERY ELECTION, ARE
YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU WERE
FOUR YEARS AGO.
I THINK THE ANSWER IS PRETTY
CLEAR.
ON EVERY SINGLE PROMISE THAT THE
PRESIDENT MAKE MAKE US, THE
PRESIDENT KEEP US.
SHOWING THE PRESIDENT’S APPROVAL
NUMBERS ARE AT AN ALL-TIME HIGH.
ACCORDING TO THE SAME POLL,
AMERICANS CONFIDENCE IN THE
ECONOMY IS HIGHER THAN THAT OF
ANY POINT IN THE PAST TWO
DECADES.
AT NATIONAL SATISFACTION IS THE
HIGHEST IN NEARLY 15 YEARS.
IN FACT, IT IS THE HIGHEST
ECONOMIC APPROVAL RATING NOT
ONLY FOR DONALD TRUMP UP FOR
PRESIDENT SINCE GEORGE W. BUSH
ENJOYED THE STRATOSPHERIC JOB
APPROVAL RATINGS IN THE FIRST
FEW MONTHS AFTER THE
SEPTEMBER 11TH, 2001 TERROR
ATTACK.
LOOK AT THIS POLL.
THE PRESIDENT’S APPROVAL RATING
IS ABOVE 50% AND EXPANDING.
SURPRISE, SURPRISE, IT LOOKS
LIKE THE PRESIDENT’S
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE PAYING OFF
AND DEMOCRATS THREE PLUS YEARS
OF DOING NOTHING ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING EXCEPT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES LIES, HOAXES, AND
WITCH HUNTS, ARE NOT
PARTICULARLY DOING WELL FOR
THEM.
TOMORROW THE INSANE CHARADE WILL
BE OVER.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE ACQUITTED
WITH THE EVEN POSSIBLE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SUSAN COLLINS, MADE IT
COMPELLING CASE WHY SHE IS
VOTING NO ON BOTH ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
SHE’S MOANING TO ACQUIT.
AND YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
ANDINAT 273 DAYS WILL BE THE ULT